[Music]
I'm subterra Mukherjee I lead the
product marketing function for our data
analytics and IOT business areas and
today we have a really really
interesting topic we're going to focus
on the total economic impact of moving
data analytics workloads to cloud how do
you evaluate some of the options we will
be joined by Mike Leon he's a senior
analyst from ESG and price Strategy
Group and Sam King who is an engineering
manager from nuna health and they're
going to share some of their insights so
why do we choose this particular topic
Google cloud is a fairly deep technical
conference but when we engage with
customers a lot of them one of the
common recurring theme that we hear from
them that we have the best technologies
in our on-premise data centers or on
cloud X or Y if we move to Google cloud
how is it going to impact our cost or
our total economic value so it's
important for us to understand that all
data warehouses that are running in the
cloud are not the same
all Hadoop or Spock workloads that could
run on different clouds are not the same
so how do we essentially evaluate those
options through some fine grained
parameters and come up with a TCO model
that's long term that's going to give
you a long term value so today we are
going to talk about why economic impact
in the cloud specially for data
analytics matters some of the key
considerations for evaluating the
economic impact and then we will take
two use cases one moving data warehouses
to the cloud and we will talk about
moving data warehouse to bigquery as an
example and mike is going to take us
through the economic rationale and
economic modeling for that and then we
are going to talk to you Sam they have
actually moved their own premised data
management platform to Google cloud what
were some of their decision criteria
what has been their experience so far
and then we're going to go to the next
use case of talking Hadoop and spark
movement to cloud and how to evaluate
the economic impact for that particular
one and then come to some conclusion
hopefully it'll be a useful session for
all of you so with that I'll first
handle the presentation to Mike to talk
about
why cloud matters and wydad analytics
Mike thanks sup how's everybody doing
exciting first day so enterprise
strategy group is an analyst and
strategy firm anchored an end user
market research and validation services
so we conduct annual research throughout
the year across various segments with
NIT and one of our most popular surveys
is our IT spending and tension survey
that's where we ask mid market and
enterprise class organizations where
they're placing their bets what are they
spending their money on
over the next 12 to 18 months and within
that survey we track technology adoption
challenges pain points etc and obviously
one of the major trends is around cloud
and this year the survey show that 85%
of organizations are leveraging cloud
computing services to some degree now of
course there are three buckets of
consuming cloud computing services
software's or services
is in the lead but but the big takeaway
here is platform as a service is is
gaining traction organizations are
starting to realize the benefits of
being able to abstract the hardware and
focus on the data and on the
applications so with that in mind I'm
sure many of you have already migrated
to the cloud we leveraged our research
to understand what are some of the
advantages of moving to the cloud and
and this is general this isn't specific
to analytics and and far and away it's
cost savings right and of course there's
a bunch of other items that we can talk
about here here are the additional items
flexibility accessibility reliability
manageability and what not but but the
big thing to think about is all of these
items can come back to cost
accessibility how is your cost a revenue
impacted if there's downtime there's a
failure with reliability apexis is a big
thing that we're going to focus on so
now let's shift to use cases far and
away the major use case right now is
lifting shift with ayahs and PA's
consumers the next use case on the list
is leveraging public cloud computing
services for analytics sothank data
warehousing data processing bi etc and I
found that really interesting the reason
it's interesting to me is this was a
more popular used
then leveraging the cloud as a cold
storage tier as a backup target for
archive 4dr
so I thought that that was pretty
impressive and now let's talk a little
about spend what our mid-market and
enterprise organizations spending on
over the next 12 to 18 months and the
interesting piece here is there's
there's an interesting marriage I think
between these two items so over 50% of
organizations are going to spend more on
cloud computing services they're also
going to spend more on data analytic
solutions and and and becoming more
data-driven so when you put the two
together you know organizations aren't
just going to take out their checkbooks
and say yeah I need these things
everybody else is doing it I need to
remain competitive they need to evaluate
the costs and and when you're evaluating
costs especially going from on-prem to
the cloud you need to think about it a
little differently so I'm gonna share
with you what I think is a good
high-level framework where you can start
to map out how those costs differ
specifically when you're moving
analytics from on-prem to the cloud so
the first bucket is really traditional
capex but to make it fair for the cloud
we have to account for if you're
leveraging a cloud service where you're
paying an upfront cost so think of this
as a cost that you have to pay before
you're starting to realize value so I
bought the solution but it's sitting
idle I'm still working on configuring
deploying testing etc the next to really
account for the fact that you're gonna
have monthly costs associated with
consuming cloud resources we have
another category around just cloud costs
so a month-to-month costs associated
with storage compute streaming ingest
excetera now is where I think it gets a
little interesting when we shift from
capex to OPEX and this is really where I
feel the cloud shines so when we when we
bucket eyes op X we do it in two ways
first it's just you know traditional op
X so that's time and manpower spent
dealing with deployment configuration
procurement etc this isn't necessarily
focused on the actual application or the
data that's what the next category is
for which is around the administration
costs so a good way to think about the
administration cost obviously I have it
here
and what you're doing on a daily basis
but it's really more about an IT
administrator and the amount of time
they spend responding to end-users so if
you're an IT administrator and you're
serving as a gatekeeper to some degree
the example here is around query
orchestration if you need to prevent end
users from accessing the system in an
unlimited way there's a cost that's
gonna be associated with that finally
maybe the most straightforward here
maintenance costs something support
professional services etc so to boil it
up when we think TCO it really requires
a different frame of thinking when
you're leveraging the cloud for data
analytics it's not just capex if
anything it's really about understanding
the optics behind it so first and
foremost you're really overcoming those
traditional cost burdens you don't have
to worry about configuration deployment
you don't have to worry about over
provisioning resources if you're
leveraging the right cloud platform and
simplicity is a big deal for a couple
reasons first it's about empowering the
IT generalist you don't really have to
worry about that that that skilled admin
dedicating a ton of their time to deal
with and user requests when you're
leveraging the cloud platform and that
simplicity extends to the business if
you have the right system that's easy to
use intuitive you can really allow the
business analyst to take matters into
their own hands in a controlled
environment right we don't wanna give
them access to everything and with that
simplicity it actually extends for the
IT admin around cost transparency
visibility into what those end-users are
doing and and that's a pretty big deal
and and you know yield some pretty
significant cost savings now the first
three items I talked about here
they're obviously clear positives for
the cloud right
yeah great we're gonna save a ton of
money going on the cloud there's gonna
be some additional cost you have to
think about one of those is if you're
leveraging streaming applications when
you're not necessarily migrating in bulk
but when you're ingesting on a day to
day basis and monthly basis you're going
to incur costs the good news is that
they make tools available to make sure
that it's reliable highly available the
workflows they're sustained
let's enter so a lot of those items can
be quantified you can put a dollar value
down that's associated with all those
things where organizations tend not to
look is around the opportunity cost and
you know there's a lot of angles to
opportunity costs what I would say is
there's so many organizations now that
our data organizations if not every
organizations a data organization they
understand that data is their most
valuable asset they want to be more
data-driven they want to leverage a
system that can respond to the business
in real-time or near real-time and they
want to make sure that that system it
allows for end users and IT admins to do
more for the organization they want
everybody focusing on the core business
with that in mind if you're allowed or
enabled by the platform you're using to
let more end-users analysts leverage
assistant to try and derive insight
you're going to increase collaboration
across the entire organization and
that's a pretty big deal so with that in
mind I'm gonna shift back to SAP who is
gonna talk about two use cases that he
mentioned earlier first we're gonna be
chatting about bigquery yeah absolutely
thanks Mike so let's make it real I
think we talked about some of the
frameworks we talked to evaluate cost
both capex and OPEX
but we're going to look at two specific
use cases one is moving your data
warehouse to bigquery let's try to
quantify some of these benefits so how
many of you are aware of what's bigquery
quick show of hands Wow we all love
bigquery it's a great product so
bigquery is Google clouds native data
warehouse system it's a server less data
warehouse that doesn't require you to
pre-configured nodes and clusters or do
capacity planning you can get your data
in write sequel queries get your answers
it's very simple it's let's keep it that
way there are a lot of benefits of
bigquery like it's it's highly durable
and encrypted secure it allows real-time
streaming data analytics but we will try
to see how all of these benefits play a
role in terms of the TCO so this is
bigquery's architecture so it's
fundament
different from traditional data
warehouses in a way the bigquery does
decoupling of storage and compute so
what it means is you can when you get
your data inside bigquery you can store
your data replicas knit replicated
highly distributed and consistent
storage system with very high
reliability and durability and when you
fire a query to get an answer from your
data only then Google dynamically
provisions compute infrastructure to
query the data and get you the insights
that you need so your compute
infrastructure which is most cost very
very costly is not running all the time
unlike many other cloud-based data
warehousing system and then there are
there are other benefits that we're
going to talk about in this context so
the first thing is in in a traditional
word data warehouse those of us who have
operated in traditional driver house you
typically load your data overnight next
day morning you will get this management
reports based on the historical data you
do a lot of bi and and kind of
descriptive analytics on top of your
data you use like traditional ETL tools
you have a DBA the person is doing like
defragmentation on disk creating indexes
refactoring some of the storage systems
you need to kind of do putting a lot of
operations overhead to make your data
data warehouse responsive and keep
thread our house like up and running but
B code changes a lot of those
traditional mold around data warehousing
right so we have automated data delivery
like unlike like traditional data
warehousing you order a data warehouse
on-premise you get like an empty box and
you need to kind of spend three months
to get the data warehouse up and running
in some of the other clouds also what
you get is a bunch of nodes and clusters
where in bigquery we have connectors for
direct SAS application like Adwords and
YouTube so you can immediately get
starting start getting data from those
applications directly into bigquery
bigquery also lays the foundation for AI
not just bi we do support a lot of bi
and reporting on top of data stored in
bigquery with partner tools like
Leuchars and tableaus of the world and
also lies with Google Theater studio but
we also support ai and tensorflow has
direct connectivity you will hear some
of the newer announcements we are going
to make in this area Vic we also
supports real-time streaming data
insights so that means you can
actually start streaming real-time data
directly inside bigquery and start
populating the data warehouse with
real-time data and then a lot of data
operations like there's no concept of
indexing or essentially taking backups
etc it's all of those data operation
steps have been automated so if we have
to translate all of this and quantify so
what like does it impact my TCO it does
and we actually had ESG and then years
she actually conducted a study to
understand if bigquery is architectural
a very very different data warehouse how
does it actually impact customers TCO so
Mike what were some of the findings
banks up so SAP mentioned we we
conducted a 3-year TCO analysis and we
compared on-premise acid upin Amazon
redshift to Google bigquery and one of
the things I want to call out very
important to call out we looked at
Amazon redshift reserved instance
pricing and we compared it to big
queries on demand pricing and you're
probably saying well wait a minute
that's not fair and really one of the
reasons we did that is because we were
talking to some of the customers it
ended up that leveraging on demand was
more cost-effective for them than
leveraging reserved instance now I
understand the predictability side of it
and that's fine and everybody can have
their their views but so we took that
approach based on what we're hearing
from customers we leveraged end-user
market research we leveraged you know
publicly available pricing which is
fantastic about the cloud and then we
did qualitative interviews with a number
of Google bigquery customers to
understand where they were and where
they are now what kind of pain points
that they have with their previous
solution and what benefits have they
gained since leveraging bigquery and
those customers came from a dupe to
bigquery that came from reg shifted
bigquery they actually came from
redshift back to on Prem back to
bigquery
which I thought was pretty interesting
so we took all that data and we created
a model and that model was spread across
three different organizations that that
we just kind of threw out there as good
starting points small medium and large
organization now some of the
considerations when you're looking at an
enterprise data warehouse we factored in
number of data citizens you know
analysts that are actually doing the
coring how much data is stored how
much data is queried of the data that's
stored and then factored in streaming
applications because you're going to
incur additional costs now I know these
three your savings are pretty
eye-popping you don't really expect it
so I can't just show you the numbers I
gotta show you a little bit what goes
behind the numbers right so we actually
went into I know this is a night chart
this is one of many sheets and this is
really boiling it up but the important
takeaway is you know the buckets I
mentioned earlier we started with those
buckets and then we added line on him
one underneath underneath underneath and
started factoring in cost and taking all
the information that was available and
applying it to the three organizations
that we were modeling and and one of the
takeaways here is while bigquery
provided savings or was at least equal
to redshift in a number of cases where
it really shined was on the effects side
so you can see here about I want to say
three or four buckets down you're going
to see significant savings on bigquery
so why is that well bigquery markets
itself as a pass and it is a pass it's
it's surplus you don't have to worry
about the infrastructure at all that
takes a massive amount of savings out
from redshift which you still have to
manage some of the infrastructure now
it's a perfectly fine solution and and
and that's fine but when you would look
at costs you really have to understand
that you're gonna be spending time
spinning up instances and selecting
instances scaling up instances so the
infrastructure really is not abstracted
that abstraction has a major impact on
savings so again looking back at the
savings and I'll leave it up there for a
little longer this time
first and foremost in the modeled
organizations and this is important to
reiterate and that was for those three
modeled organizations there are going to
be organizations that could potentially
have larger savings there could be
organizations that may not have savings
at all and that's fair and Google knows
that we know that everybody knows that
but first and foremost going from on
front to the cloud you're going to save
money but what you're going to see here
is the cloud provider that you select
really matters so if you're looking just
at this medium-sized organization great
I can say if $300,000 go in a redshift
well I can save another 1.7 million
dollars over three years going to
bigquery for again this modeled
organization
so the point here is one you really need
to understand your costs to accurately
model your specific organization so some
of the takeaways from the validation
first on the infrastructure side with
bigquery you can leverage on demand
pricing so there's no upfront investment
which is fantastic and then you really
don't have to worry about over
provisioning resources because they spin
up automatically based on the demand of
the of the query next on the OP X side
don't worry about sizing don't worry
about maintenance really empowering that
generalist to do more and finally cloud
costs a few things I want to talk about
first simplified pricing it's all
publicly available you can see it they
pay for storage you pay for processed
data and then you pay for streaming now
obviously that's for on-demand flat rate
pricing is probably similar to reserved
instance pricing we can ask SAP later
but I believe that's true you don't have
to worry about scaling compute because
it's done automatically and finally the
last piece how many people have had
issues with interoperability when
they're deploying a big data
infrastructure anyone ok cool that would
have been embarrassing if nobody raised
their hand but for the most part Google
handles the interoperability side of
incorporating new technologies so you
pretty much keep leveraging the platform
you have no idea that you're actually
leveraging the latest and greatest
technology because they take care of the
integration to that for you
so with that mind I'm gonna hand it over
to to SAP and Sam and Sam's gonna share
some experiences he's had thanks Mike
that's really helpful inside but let's
make it real laugh so we have Sam King
and Sam is then engineering manager in
nuna health they're a start-up based out
of San Francisco and you want to quickly
talk about know now what you guys do and
then we can jump into the specific topic
of moving data warehouse to bigquery
yeah so nuna as a company tries to help
folks understand health data so that
they can make better decisions folks
like the government with Medicare and
Medicaid as well as employer sponsored
health plans and insurance plans
great and then you were dealing with a
lot of data every company is no
exception I'm sure
so before you move to bigquery what was
the on premised system that we were
using yeah so we pretty quickly made the
decision that we wanted to be on the
cloud but our previous solution before
we were on bigquery we started out with
open source distributed query engine and
this worked fine to start out with but
once we were scaling up we started
running into a lot of problems with it
queries that used to take second started
taking minutes there were a lot of
errors that we were encountering even
with pretty small queries and also in
order to deal with a lot of that we
needed to over-provision the cluster
which resulted in a pretty high cost and
as a result we knew that we would be
able to fix those problems but it would
have taken a lot of time so we started
to look into different alternatives okay
and then eventually you move to bigquery
so can you please take us through like
what was your kind of decision-making
criteria what about the process that you
kind of followed yeah so at NU now we're
a data-driven company we try to put a
lot of discipline between all of the
decisions that we make and so for this
one we put together a spreadsheet you
can see a model of it up there and you
can see bigquery is on the right we also
evaluated bigquery against a bunch of
other different solutions including
hosted ones as well as self hosted
solutions similar to the status-quo
solution that we have on the far left
there on the each of the rows you can
see a different thing that we care about
so you can see we really care about
stability and so that's weighted as a
critical feature and there are a bunch
of other ones that are listed and you
might be wondering why we have some of
these features in a talk about cost and
part of this is expanding the notion of
what you think of as total cost of
ownership so when you we talk about
stability for us that really is a cost
concern because if we miss our customer
SLA is then we're not getting paid same
deal with things like operational
experience if we already know how to do
something then we don't need to invest
time and the human cost
there in order to learn about a new
technology and so we took all of these
things that we care about we weighted
them and then we filled out how good is
each of these technologies in each of
these categories so you can see for our
status quo solution
it actually rates good in terms of
operational experience because we
already have some experience using it we
knew what the problems were
whereas with overall stability that
rated poor because of all the errors
that we were talking about the next
thing that we did after we filled out a
draft of this was reach out to a bunch
of other folks throughout the company to
get their opinion on this so share the
spreadsheet we got folks including the
BI teams including the CTO including
some non-technical folks in the company
who primarily care about cost to comment
on each of these weightings on each of
these values so that the company as a
whole could come to an agreement in
terms of making this decision and that
was one of the most important parts of
this process because initially there was
a lot of resistance in the company to
going multi-cloud but because the
decision process was so collaborative
and transparent we were able to get the
buy-in that we needed and you can see at
the very bottom there there some scores
so we used the sidebar on the right and
we multiplied the weights by each of the
values summed it up to come to those
scores and then we did a
proof-of-concept with bigquery as well
as a hosted solution number one and when
we did that we found that bigquery was
even easier than we had predicted to
prototype and get running so we switched
over to using that yeah and a new node
deals with a lot of healthcare data
right you mentioned you are in the
business of healthcare so regulatory
compliance and security these are like
important consideration how did it how
do you evaluate those options in the
cloud yeah absolutely at nuna because we
deal with healthcare data we have a
saying every row of data is a life and
so privacy and security for that data is
absolutely a top concern and for us one
of the biggest features of bigquery and
Google cloud platform when we were
making this decision was projects within
Google cloud platform so project is
basically full separation of all of the
resources including bigquery as well as
Google Cloud Storage and any other
service that you use and at nuna we care
a lot about data separation because we
need to keep each of our clients data
separate from one another with our other
cloud we had to write a lot of custom
code in order to achieve that and that's
pretty expensive to maintain because not
only if there were a security breach
would that be very costly but the amount
of time that it takes us to understand
all of the multi-tenancy support that
we've built in and just to develop those
technologies are pretty significant and
so with bigquery we just use separate
projects and that works pretty
transparently for us and in addition to
that it helps improve the cost
transparency and general the cost
controls that we have rights and what
has been the experience thus far we have
been in bigquery for a couple of years
now
yeah we've been using bigquery for a
little over a year and so our experience
has been very positive both in terms of
human costs as well as machine costs
we've seen cost reductions when move
into bigquery from the human cost
perspective if we had stayed with that
open-source technology we would have
needed to invest time in improving the
scalability reducing latency reducing
error rates and improving multi-tenancy
support and each of those things would
have taken multiple engineer months and
as a start-up we really needed we really
didn't have that time and even if that
were a good use of human time and we
with bigquery on the other hand it only
took us a couple of weeks to build out
the infrastructure and automation to
switch over and another couple of weeks
to move over our sequel to the new
dialect and since then it's been pretty
hands-off so from a human perspective
the costs have been much lower and then
from a machine perspective it's been an
even bigger win since as mentioned
earlier the separation between storage
and compute on bigquery has been big for
us since we have a lot of data that we
need to store but that we don't query
very often and in addition to that we
have a lot of customers that need to
have access to all of their data within
a few seconds but they might only query
it once a week and so because of that we
need to support very bursty query
patterns and bigquery has been great
about that and the only way that we were
able to support that with our open
source solution was by dramatically over
provisioning the cluster so switching to
bigquery has reduced the cost for us all
around great great thanks for sharing
the insights Sam thanks for coming over
really appreciate thank you so moving on
talking about the the use case to I
think the the need somebody from the
bigquery conversation is not all the
data warehouses that are running in the
cloud or the SEM we need to be really
careful to understand how those data
warehouses that design how they're they
are architected how it's going to
support your business your very specific
use case your requirements to come to a
TCO model the second one is moving
Hadoop and spark to cloud again how many
of you are using some form of Hadoop or
spark for data processing a lot of you
create we all love open source Google
cloud is committed to innovate and while
we innovate we are also embracing the
best of the Apache open source project
for data processing data proc is a fully
managed service that runs on our cloud
for Apache Hadoop and spark we just
announced the support for Apache
workflow for Apache airflow for workflow
orchestrations but let's talk about this
particular use case so this is a typical
lifecycle of Hadoop and spark cluster
implementation right so you first obtain
the hardware server configure the server
install the OSS then go through multiple
iteration of reconfiguration
optimization debugging and then finally
process the data it's a it's a pretty
labor-intensive process
and we are working with companies really
large planet-scale
internet companies like Yahoo's of the
world Twitter just announced that
they're going to move like thousands of
hadoop clusters to Google Cloud we are
working with disruptive startups who are
like very lean ly resourced but managing
a huge amount of data and then we are
also working with large enterprise
companies like the Home Depot's of the
world the HSBC's of the world and they
are moving their big data processing
workloads to Google cloud there is a
reason behind it so some when we get to
conversations with customers and we
typically ask so you're using your
Hadoop and spark solutions on-premise or
in some other cloud what are some of the
cool challenges that you face
I think scaling is a major major problem
like especially with spiky workloads
with lot of seasonality involved where
the data volume could be unpredictable
scaling often chokes customer down
because they have pre provision capacity
and in expanding that it's going to take
a lot of time utilization and this is
the flipside of over-provisioning like
if you have to provision for the most
spiky workload then you end up creating
an underutilized infrastructure for you
have to be accountable to your CFO hey
my resource utilization is less than 20%
why should I keep continuing this in my
data center and then if you try to
optimize either of these two you
encounter a lot of cost pin like if you
keep changing your cluster configuration
you'll have to keep reprovision in your
hardware infrastructure if there's a lot
of cost associated with it like not only
just hardware cost but professional
services that comes along with it so
what Google cloud offers in this space
is state approximants Park Service that
allows you to run like Hadoop and spark
jobs on our cloud and data proc is an
interesting service so there are there
are a couple of options for companies to
run Hadoop and spark jobs on Google
Cloud one is if you're running it on
premise
you pretty much do everything for for
running a data processing job you write
like custom code you do like monitoring
of the health of the of the cluster
scaling job submission connectivity
deployment like everything pretty much
then if you choose to move your Hadoop
and spark job as a
p.m. option on GCE Google compute engine
and Google cloud you still do a bit of
automation like connectivity deployment
creation those steps are taken care of
by Google cloud but the rest of the
thing you still have to do as a company
and then when you move to data proc it's
fully managed so almost the only thing
that you do is just writing custom cords
rest of the things are taken care of by
the platform and by the way small plugin
we're going to have a really interesting
announcement around data proc on
Wednesday that's tomorrow know that I
can't talk now I wish I could but we had
a year's G and and they came again just
to prove the same point that not all
Hadoop and spark managed services that
are running in the cloud are the same so
how is data proc different from some of
the other alternates that are out in the
market and if a customer is already
running it in unpromising why should
they even bother to move to cloud so so
Mike you want to share some of the
insights from that research so when
evaluating TCO for Hadoop spark there's
a couple of obvious considerations right
you know node count how many nodes are
you gonna have in a cluster what are
your resource requirements what's your
workload demand those are two pretty
obvious costs now we start get to tricky
areas daily run time is your is your
existing cluster running 24/7 or is
there downtime then if there's downtime
how much is it down are you running back
for requests during the evening hours
then during the day you're allowing for
ad hoc querying while while you're doing
back at the same time and and with that
in mind the ad hoc whirring starts
factoring in that IT administration time
so is your IT administrator or are you
kind of a gatekeeper are you trying to
prevent analysts from running ad hoc
queries because they could potentially
disrupt back from queries that are going
on it you know almost 24/7 to some
degree so you really have to factor in
that those costs and you have to
understand the types of runtimes that
your environments working with and
finally burst requirements SAP mentioned
this you have to plan for over
provisioning
when your on-prem with a cloud it's not
necessarily something you have to think
about because you can easily scale up
you can easily scale down that
elasticity of the cloud provides enables
you to say to save costs when there is
downtime so we leveraged the same
buckets as before but we broke it down a
little differently to account for for
Hadoop and and SPARC at some degree and
we broke out server and storage separate
because you know it's decoupled we also
factored in an infrastructure
infrastructure here happens to be
specifically associated with power
cooling floor space that kind of stuff
and then finally administration and
those cloud costs so take away one
you're gonna save money regardless of
the cloud provider you use for the
organization that wood that we modeled
here key takeaways save up to 70% or
more on the reduction in hardware that's
a big savings op X side of things you
could save up to 85% going from to the
cloud based based on what we modeled
here and some of the key points around
EMR versus data proc in this case you're
gonna see the same similar areas of
savings that we saw with bigquery around
administration around cloud it's not as
drastic I would say as the bigquery side
but you're still going to gain an
economic advantage by leveraging
bigquery in this case now the last piece
I want to mention is at the bottom here
it's agility and this goes to the
opportunity costs so when we were
talking to customers and interviewing
them as part of the study these are
quotes from three different customers
across three different verticals
unrelated that I thought was interesting
that again we can't quantify but there's
definitely a cost associated with it so
first is around being able to leverage a
platform that will allow you to increase
current revenue streams there's a
business demand for something you can
easily access it in the cloud and you
can satisfy the requirements of that
workload next is being able to
capitalize on a new opportunity and
being able to again leverage that
scalable system that can instantaneously
cater to your workload demands
and finally the last piece and and and I
found this one interesting I've heard
this multiple times so far over the
course of the last two days from
customers who leveraged not just data
proc but a number of GCP services the
ability to succeed but more importantly
fail faster and I want to I want to go
on this for for just a second you know
if you're leveraging a cloud service and
you're able to provide access to more
people in your organization you're gonna
obviously be able to to gain insights
faster and with that in mind you'll
understand if you're going to be able to
continue down the path of an initiative
to have or you can just stop and say you
know what this isn't going to be
successful let's move on to the next one
that is something that this particular
organization was able to do multiple
times and they really emphasize the fail
faster so with that in mind I'm gonna
shift back to SAP and he's going to
highlight a couple of other customers
that weren't part of our study to
highlight a couple of other quantitative
or qualitative savings thanks Mike so
just to kind of rephrase some of these
concepts and make it real we took two
examples one a traditional enterprise
very traditional but but really great
organization Telegraph group they run
one of the most popular newspapers in UK
more than 90 million subscribers they
were facing challenges to understand
customer sentiment and to
personalization because their existing
systems that they had for the data
warehouse were not able to scale for the
type of analysis that they are trying to
do so what they did was they first tried
another cloud hosted Hadoop arm offering
just to see like if they can offload
that particular part of the workload and
run their and continued to run their own
from eyes data warehouse system it was
just not scalable that systems were not
talking to each other the cost was going
through the roof so they finally started
doing a POC with bigquery and then
started using it now Telegraph media is
essentially analyzing more than four
terabyte of data less than a minute they
they minimize their cost per query look
at how fine-grained some of these
customers are going they're essentially
trying to track how many times the data
warehouse is getting queried what's the
volume of data that is getting worried
what
cost per query and they are seeing cost
per query saving that's like the
ultimate realization of the value from a
data warehouse and then it reduces their
overall data analysis time from from
hours to minutes and it's making the
whole organization much more responsive
they're able to launch campaigns for
their customers much more responsibly
rather than waiting for days or weeks
for IT teams to get back to them with
results and in the other example that we
took is a disruptive startup so so
Accardo is one of the largest online
retailers based out of UK and they're
redefining grocery experience through
online web and mobile application and
and okada you can you can read about a
part of there are multiple articles
coming and economists like how they're
disrupting the whole industry they are
one of our big query customers and
picado is dealing with massive massive
amount of data hundreds of terabytes of
data and they they were like they had
two concerns one is like scale because
they are moving so fast growing so fast
they wanted the data analytics
infrastructure to support that growth
and the second thing is while they grow
and while they become responsive they
can't have like unprecedented cost
exposure on the data analytics side so
they came to Google cloud they're not
only just using bigquery but they're
using a whole other set of tools in
using data prog GCS and what they got is
one query performance it improved
dramatically after moving to bigquery so
faster time to insight it increased
their contact center efficiency they're
using otologist our data analytics tag
but machine learning to do labeling for
emails automatic responses back to their
customers and Mike talked about
opportunity cost like this is how the
company is realizing opportunity cost by
reducing inventory churn by by being
more responsive and reaching out to the
customers on time and saving lost sales
and and you have to start quantifying
those numbers by factoring an
opportunity cost so we talked a lot
about different concepts and frameworks
give you use cases we had new now we
talked about customers so how do you
take it back home and start applying for
your businesses so few things if you
have to remember I think I just
summarized them and we are having a
conversation right before this
presentation if I have to summarize this
we call
TLDR in google too long to read so
basically all that glitters is not gold
all the data warehouses that are running
in the cloud were not designed for cloud
so if you're evaluating options start
thinking about a long term horizon not
just what's the upfront cost of option A
versus B it could be it could be a
one-year two-year or three-year horizon
best on your your cost appetite and
exposure appetite the second thing is go
beyond capex just don't think about okay
how much I have already invested what's
my sunk cost what's my capex going to be
and how much myopic is going to be it's
not a capex vs. hapax comparison we need
to factor in other cost build a
framework Luna showed like how they how
they went granular they build a
framework that was pretty exhaustive
that actually was designed for their
specific business use case so for your
business you have to build your own
framework factor in business priorities
scoping data growth the amount of data
that you have in your system it's not
going to remain the same over the course
of next 2 or 3 years and that's going to
be the number one blocker for you to
grow user consideration usage pattern
like how many users are bi user how many
users are doing ad hoc analysis how many
of them are you doing kira science or
machine learning workflows and goo
granular specificity and granularity is
very important in cost consideration and
then consider opportunity cost like
Accardo for example or the Telegraph
media they're all thinking about how is
my data management platform going to
support my business vision and goal and
then compare cost with next viable
options like hey bigquery cost X amount
of dollar is just not enough if it is
not bigquery
if it is redshift or if it is my own
premised Hadoop system what are some of
the next viable options do you have and
then do a comparative study across those
options and then pick your best bit so
with that I think we have come to the
conclusion of this particular
presentation I hope you you've got
something that's new we refresh some of
the memories for sure like talking about
bigquery for those who are already using
it or data proc will be here
staying out to take questions and have
conversations with you I really want to
thank
Sam from nuna and then Mike from ESG for
the participation and thank all of you
for your presence here
really appreciate thank you
[Music]